[Musique]
au même instant sur l'ensemble de la
planète vin volcans sont en éruption
certains sont réveillés depuis quelques
heures
d'autres depuis des mois parfois des
siennes
pour tenter de comprendre les mécanismes
qui transforme continuellement notre
planète
les volcanologues défi constamment les
colères de la nature
ils doivent savoir où et quand le
prochain volcan peut frapper
[Musique]
au 21ème siècle comme depuis plusieurs
centaines de millions d'années
la plupart des volcans naissent et
meurent sur les frontières d'une croûte
terrestre constamment en mouvement
porte d'entrée vers le coeur brûlant et
bouillonnant de notre planète
ces colosses menace à chaque instant
d'anéantir la vie qui s'est installé à
proximité
je
pour éviter les tragédies on demande
alors aujourd'hui aux scientifiques
d'être en mesure d'anticiper et de
prévenir on leur demande de devenir des
prophètes et de savoir analyser les
moindres manifestation des volcans
partout dans le monde il met alors leurs
outils et leurs connaissances à
disposition pour tenter de protéger ceux
qui vivent sous le feu de la terre
[Musique]
au coeur des andes est la vallée reculée
du rio pas elle est particulièrement
exposée aux dangers d'un volcan géant le
nevado del oui là son glacier culmine à
plus de 5400 mètres d'altitude
et en cas d'éruption c'est le risque
d'effondrement de cette calotte gelés
qui constitue le plus grand danger pour
les paysans colombiens de ces montagnes
même une faible éruption peut faire
céder le glacier suspendu au dessus de
la balle et les tonnes de glace et d'eau
ainsi libéré entraînerait dans leur
chute la terre la roche et les arbres
pour former une avalanche contact
meurtrière que rien n'arrêtera sur des
centaines de kilomètres
[Applaudissements]
déjà en 1994 un tremblement de terre
dévastait les gorges du riou plus de
1000 personnes trouvèrent la mort sous
les glissements de terrain charriés par
la rivière
cette catastrophe sonna comme un
avertissement une éruption faisant céder
le glacier aurait pu être une tragédie
plus grande encore et fait planer depuis
une menace sur toute la vallée
[Musique]
quinze ans plus tard pour éviter un
nouveau drame
les volcanologues colombiens ont placé
sous surveillance le nevado toutes les
données arrivent à l'observatoire de
popayan 3,6 landgraf ont été installées
autour du volcan pour surveiller ses
battements de coeur qui se gravent dans
la suite adriana resterez peau coordonne
les équipes qui se relaient jour et nuit
les secousses de plus en plus forte et
de plus en plus rapprochées ont fait
passer le volcan en alerte rouge
signifiant que l'éruption est imminente
[Musique]
en plus des sismographes l'équipe team
géomines as a mis en place une série
d'instruments pour protéger la
population indigène des avalanches en
pleine période de haute activité
scientifiques et techniciens doivent
fréquemment partir sur le terrain
vérifier les stations dans cette région
inaccessible
il leur faut presque deux jours pour
atteindre les gorges dans lesquelles ont
été déployés les instruments
[Applaudissements]
maintenant et ça s'est stationné cnn ou
n'a cessé son action contiennent des
capteurs qui reçoivent les vibrations
susceptibles d'être produits par une
avalanche
elles sont en plus accompagné d'un
système d'alarmé sonore qui informe la
population qu'une coulée de boue est en
train d'arriver
la larme à la caisse coaching il
s'épanche les gens peuvent alors réagir
et rejoindre les sites sur préalablement
identifiés si détecteur d'avalanche ont
été ainsi placé dans le fond des vallées
qui entoure le volcan chacun est équipé
d'une alarme sonore pour prévenir la
population alentour
le travail de prévention est nécessaire
pour protéger ces paysans colombiens
répartis dans des milliers de petites
habitations clairsemé tout au long de la
vallée un véritable effort de
sensibilisation effet dans les
carrefours de vie où tout le monde doit
se croiser un jour
votre attention s'il vous plaît l'alerté
rouge est maintenue signifiant possible
éruption du volcan nevado del ruiz à une
fissure dans la partie arrière peut
rentrer une plaque de glace provoquer
une avalanche
cette annonce est valable dans toute la
communauté dean ça et tout ce qui se
trouve sur les rives du rio paris
le message n'est pas toujours facile à
faire passer pour les scientifiques dans
ces montagnes où la culture indigène est
la plus forte du pays
certains chaman regrette la disparition
progressive d'une mémoire ancestrale 6
face à lui on pense trop vite que l'on
est hors de danger
il peut provoquer une éruption plus
grande encore qui peut faire disparaître
des villages entiers
le nevado a soif lui aussi mais comme
personne ne s'en rappellent ils
explosent pour qu'on se rende compte
qu'il existe les blancs ne se rendent
pas compte de ce qui va arriver parce
qu'ils ne connaissent pas la langue ne
savent regarder que les cahiers les
livres mais ils ne ressentent rien dans
le corps
sur les feuilles de suite apparaissent
maintenant plusieurs centaines de
secousses quotidienne l'activité du
nevado ne cesse d'augmenter le feu qui
lui brûle les entrailles devra bientôt
le faire exploser
[Musique]
- joie
dans les bureaux comme sur le terrain
les volcanologues met tout en oeuvre
pour éviter les imprévus mais selmer g20
un problème à notre station relais et
que l'équipe dean géomines se rend sur
place avec l'équipement pour faire les
réparations
nous aurions donc besoin de votre aide
pour nous accompagner nous fournir
quelque chose l'antenne relais planté au
sommet des montagnes est un point
central du réseau
c'est elle qui redistribue les
informations au reste de la vallée à
plus de 4000 mètres d'altitude les
ingénieurs découvre qu'une entreprise de
téléphonie mobile a construit un
bâtiment contre leurs antennes
en ce moment le soleil est à la moitié
donc le poste devrait être placé plus ou
moins par là avant ses installations de
comme celle n'existait pas donc les
équipements fonctionner sans problème
comme on marche à l'énergie solaire
l'ombre portée par le mur qui a été
construit peut faire perdre du potentiel
en fonction de la position du soleil la
période de l'année
j'ai peiné nom est la position de son
local et de l'agneau et aux salles pour
le soleil se lève là il va se coucher
d'abord ne pourra pas la placer ailleurs
il faudra une journée complète à
l'équipe pour déplacer la station relais
et la rendre parfaitement opérationnels
le volcan semble lui attendre patiemment
que tout le monde soit prêt il vibre
respire tremble mais n'explosent
toujours pas
une des clés pour comprendre le
fonctionnement d'un volcan et prévoir
ces prochaines éruptions
c'est d'accéder au magma et à son
réservoir l'archipel d'hawaï est un
point chaud qui permettent aux
volcanologues d'approcher le coeur du
système volcanique quotidiennement le
kilauea est le volcan le plus actif au
monde
c'est pourtant l'un des moins dangereux
ces éruptions ne provoque pas de réelle
explosion mais des rivières de lave
fluide qui s'écoule lentement jusqu'à la
mer
l'observatoire volcanologique a donc été
construit au bord du cratère et les
scientifiques profitent de cet
environnement particulier de cette
proximité pour développer et tester une
série d'outils de surveillance qui
pourront servir d'autres communautés à
travers le monde
le volcan est constamment filmé et
photographié enregistré tous les
capteurs en place permettent de mieux
comprendre pour mieux développer les
instruments de demain
mike paulhan des spécialistes en
géodésie la science qui mesure les
déformations de la surface terrestre
j'essaie de le mettre aussi proche que
possible du centre de la marque
ce disque blanc là elle reçoit les
signaux et les envoie dans le récit
alors ce qu'on fait c'est qu'on laisse
tout ça là pour quelques jours afin de
collecter assez de données pour avoir
vraiment une bonne position labo on les
traite et on va être capable d'avoir la
position de ses trains ter en répétant
cela au cours du temps elle peut voir
comment le point sur place et quand on
rapporte cela tous les autres rebelles
ça nous donne une très bonne idée de
comment la surface du vacancier des
formes
alors on peut en déduire où est le magma
sous le volcan qu'on brenda et si oui
mais non le volcan risque d'entraîner
des chiens
une éruption volcanique qui est une
poussée souterraine de magma jusqu'à la
surface
la composition de ce magma sa
température sa teneur en cristaux sa
densité sa viscosité et sa capacité à
retenir les gaz dissous ont une action
primordiale sur les différents type
d'éruption à l'intérieur du volcan le
magma bouillonne et légale qu'ils
laissent échapper à travers les
fumerolles sont une signature de son
état et de sa position
un instrument capable de mesurer la
composition de ces gaz donnera des
informations précises sur la progression
de la lave et l'éventualité d'une
éruption
le principe de la télémétrie qui permet
de faire des mesures à distance sans se
mettre en danger est un des enjeux
majeurs de la recherche en volcanologie
ces techniques sont développées ici pour
mieux servir ceux qui sont en contact
avec des volcans beaucoup plus dangereux
que le kilauea
[Musique]
aux philippines le volcan mayon a été
particulièrement meurtrier dans les
années passées les terres fertiles à son
pied font vivre des milliers de paysans
qui sont les principales cibles de ses
colères
le plus à craindre est une coulée
pyroclastique un nuage de gaz brûlants
de cendres incandescentes et de roches
en fusion qui dévalent les flancs du
volcan à plus de 100 kilomètres à
l'heure
causant la mort quasi certaine de tout
ce qui se trouve sur sa route
[Musique]
en 1993 une coulée pyroclastique a
marqué la population
veronica perez est la seule de son
village à avoir survécu
d'abord il ya eu l'ère 1ère brûlant
ensuite la main avait descendu à en
roulant je me suis dit c'est quoi ça
parce que le bruit était comme celui
d'un avion
j'ai pensé un avion non en regardant
vers le haut j'ai vu des arbres tombés
et bout de cinq minutes ma peau tombés
ici et là c'est alors je me suis assise
par terre
je me suis dit à moi-même je veux vivre
je veux vivre c'est tout je veux juste
dire pour éviter de nouvelles
catastrophes les scientifiques philippin
compte aujourd'hui sur leurs instruments
en plus d'une veille visuel et d'un
réseau de sismographes l'observatoire
s'est modernisé en s'équipant d'une
batterie d'outils capables de mesurer
l'inclinaison du sol sa dilatation et
les gaz émis par le volcan
m
directeur de l'observatoire aide
laguerta est le meilleur spécialiste du
volcan mayon
les instruments sont très importants
pour anticiper les prochains et
d'options à ce que le volcan n'est pas
toujours visible il peut être recourir
de nuages et pendant la saison des
pluies
ici aux philippines ça peut durer des
mois si nous dépendions uniquement de
l'observation directe nous n'aurions pas
le temps d'évacuer les gens
pour contrer ce manque de visibilité
les volcanologues utilise un outil funny
d'hawaï le fly spec qui permet de
mesurer le dioxyde de soufre dans le
panache de fumée qui s'échappe du sommet
du volcan
en fonction de la concentration en gaz
dans le panache les scientifiques
peuvent en déduire la hauteur du magma à
l'intérieur de l'édifice dans des
conditions relativement confortable et
techniciens philippin peuvent surveiller
l'activité magmatique en enchaînant les
allers retours sous le panache la
couverture nuageuse j'ai toujours de 5%
bonnes conditions météo
[Musique]
depuis plusieurs mois le magma ne cesse
de monter dans les conduits du volcan ce
qui indique que le mayon menace d'entrer
une fois encore en éruption
[Applaudissements]
dans l'observatoire la concentration
monte au même rythme que les alertes les
scientifiques recommandent d'évacuer les
zones les plus menacées
relayée sur le terrain par la protection
civile dans un rayon de 6 km autour du
volcan l'armée est chargée de diriger
les habitants vers des centres de
réfugiés
[Musique]
l'unité européenne il y a encore des
jambes
nous n'avons pas encore serré que tout
le monde nous leur conseillons de partir
dans un lieu plus sûr pendant que le
volcan n'est pas tout à fait rêver
certains paysans préfèrent encore défié
les forces de la nature que d'abandonner
leurs récoltes et leurs bêtes leur
culture sont leur seule ressource et
l'intervention des scientifiques dans
leur vie est encore trop récente pour
être sérieusement prise en compte quand
on a fait passer l'alertent du niveau 3
au niveau 4 aujourd'hui où les gens
étaient toujours réticents à évacuer à
cause de ce qu'ils sont déjà vécu avec
le mayon parce qu'ils ont déjà connu de
nombreuses éruptions de voir des signes
physiques concret avant de se dire que
le volcan va entrer en éruption
qu'ils menacent leur commune
le 20 décembre 2009 quelques heures
seulement après que les scientifiques
ont décidé de monter l'alertent au
niveau 4 le mayon en pleine nuit a fait
une démonstration de sa puissance
plusieurs millions de tonnes de lave se
sont écoulés sur les flancs du volcan
construisant progressivement des
édifices menaçant les derniers habitants
réticences jusque là à évacuer ont alors
rejoint dans la précipitation les
centres d'évacuation
quand il avait déjà des ressentis sortie
et qu'on attendait le volcan faire du
bon goût et qui a grimpé de feu qui
descendait alors décroché nous a donné
d'évacuer les volcanologues nous avait
déjà demandé des bêtises personnes le
feu de cette fois l'éruption du mayon
n'a pas provoqué de coulées
pyroclastiques et ses épanchements de
lave se sont arrêtés avant de toucher
les zones habitées personne n'a été
touché pendant cet événement et si
certains s'amusent encore à défier le
volcan tout le monde a sans doute mieux
compris le rôle important des
volcanologues et de leurs prévisions
[Musique]
en colombie et volcanologues ont
également gagné quelques points de
crédibilité auprès de la population
l'éruption tant redoutée du nevado del
oui là c'est finalement déclenché le 21
novembre 2008 elle aussi au beau milieu
de la nuit
[Musique]
on
ans
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
comme prévu l'explosion a provoqué une
énorme coulée de boue d'arbres et de
roches qui a envahi le fond de la vallée
comme prévu le glacier a cédé et
l'avalanche a été beaucoup plus
importante que celle de 94
le matin suivant l'éruption la ville de
belles al kassar se réveille choqué
figées dans la boue
[Musique]
les rivières ont été détournés les ponts
et les routes sont coupées privant les
familles d'électricité et de tout
contact avec les grandes villes mais le
réseau de surveillance et d' alerte qui
avait été mise en place par les
volcanologues dean jéromine as a
parfaitement fonctionné
les dégâts sont surtout matériels cette
fois des milliers de vies ont été
sauvées
[Musique]
l'état d'urgence est déclaré dans un
pays qui étaient préparées à intervenir
tout le monde savait que l'éruption
était imminente
l'entraidé les secours se mettent
rapidement en place l'armée les aide
humanitaire s'organise tout au long de
la vallée paes la coulée de boue est
descendu sur plus de 150 kilos il ya un
saut au niveau de la marque sur la route
là à droite ça allait un peu plus haut
les équipes scientifiques djo minasse se
répartissent aussi sur l'ensemble de la
zone endommagée pour évaluer l'ampleur
de l'avalanche et estime et sa force
chaque petit groupe se concentre sur un
tronçon sinistrés et tente de comprendre
le chemin qu'a pris la poubelle pour
savoir où reconstruire ou se réfugier et
comment protéger au mieux les
populations lors de la prochaine et
options là où il ya les petits armes
sous la marque
je pense qu'il ya pas plus de cinq ou
six mètres là-bas mais ici c'est un peu
plus hautes écoles
après trois jours d'investigation le
géologue ou commerciales tirant un
premier bilan pour cet événement 2008
même si les chiffres ils sont pas encore
officiels il y aurait plus ou moins une
dizaine de mains c'est toujours terrible
mais je pense qu'on a réussi à faire de
travail sera toujours une menace
et c'est important d'avoir des cartes de
dangers des cartes de vulnérabilité des
cartes de risques toutes ces
informations doivent être intégrés pour
éviter qu'une tragédie comme celle de 85
à romero ou de 94 à bella cas ça arrive
de nouveau si nous les anciens on
continue de perdre la mémoire
le nevado ne se calmera pas et si le
nevado se vide de tout seul avons dit
que ses filles se réveilleront et
qu'après ce réveil il se calmera que
quand il aura ensevelis à cette personne
il se rendormir à
[Musique]
en colombie les volcanologues semble
avoir trouvé des solutions pour protéger
les populations de ces volcans recouvert
de glace mais chaque volcan a son propre
caractère sa propre identité et chacun
d'entre eux nécessitent de développer de
nouvelles stratégies de prévention et de
défense au coeur de la papouasie la baie
de rabaul n'est qu'un énorme cratère
actifs qui a construit au cours des
siècles de nombreux cônes pyroclastiques
autour de lui depuis 16 ans maintenant
toute la puissance de ras bol s'échappe
par le cône de tabou
littéralement le nid de frelons
ces explosions envoie continuellement
des nuages de cendres sur les habitants
d'une ville devenue grise
la difficulté que rencontrent ici les
scientifiques et de prévoir les
éruptions majeures de ce complexe
volcanique
car le réservoir de magma est placé sous
la mer quand ce coeur de la vous
montrent sous pression il peut soulever
le fond de la baie avant d'ouvrir de
nouvelles bouches volcaniques
la formation de ces nouveaux caunes
dégage une énergie formidable capable
d'entraîner des pluies de cendres et de
bombes des tsunamis des nuées ardentes
et des coulées pyroclastiques
le 19 septembre 1994
une de ces éruptions majeures s'est
déclenchée deux cônes volcaniques opposé
dans la baie sont entrés en éruption
simultanément détruisant la moitié de la
ville
[Musique]
la population a pourtant été sauvé de ce
cataclysme
grâce à l'initiative de l'observatoire
volcanologique en plus de l'inévitable
réseau de sismographes les scientifiques
avaient eu l'idée astucieuse de mettre
en place un système de trois marégraphes
dans la paix et ses pylônes fixé sur le
fond mesure habituellement le niveau de
la mer mais à ras bol ils ont permis de
mesurer l'élévation du fonds marins la
veille de l'éruption
en 94 le fond de la baie a enflé à tel
point que les marégraphes ont mesuré un
soulèvement de plus de 5 mètres en
quelques heures le ventre du volcan
était prête à exploser les 70000
habitants de la région ont tous été
évacués sauver dans la nuit
l'ingénieur john bosco est chargé de
maintenir le matériel en état tout au
long de l'année
[Musique]
donc c'est en train de transmettre et
vous pouvez entendre la fréquence
changer quand ils viennent pas cliente
le capteur monte et descend vous devriez
pouvoir entendre le signal varié avec la
fréquence mais les marégraphes n'ont pas
tout résolu les tonnes de cendres
volcaniques qui tombent quotidiennement
sur ras bol ronge le matériel et les
hommes ou été avec la situation ici à
cause de la cendre ses traits corrosifs
avec les gaz qui s'échappent et tout ce
qui sort du volcan les travaux de
maintenance coûte très cher
depuis le jour de l'éruption le tas pour
vour alterne les phases de sommeil et de
forte activité
si certains ont préféré se réinstaller
dans les montagnes de l'arrière pays
un tiers de la population s'attache
encore à sa terre natale et tentent de
survivre sous les poussières toxiques
[Musique]
au-delà des performances des marégraphes
et de l'ingéniosité du dispositif les
volcanologues ont besoin de mieux
comprendre les éruptions paroxysmale de
ces volcans actifs
au large de la sicile célèbre volcan
stromboli maintient lui une activité
explosive depuis près de deux mille ans
comme à hawaï
cet édifice facile d'accès attire les
volcanologues du monde entier il est
devenu aujourd'hui le volcan le mieux
surveillées au monde un véritable favori
qui permettent aux scientifiques d'aller
plus loin dans l'étude et la
compréhension de ces montagnes ardente
aux explosions quotidienne sans réel
danger pour la population
s'ajoutent certaines phases de plus
grande activité qui pose encore problème
aux scientifiques
malgré la batterie d'instruments qui a
poussé sur l'île et qui enregistre ses
moindres humeur certains événements
majeurs ne peuvent toujours pas être
anticipé en décembre 2002 très peu
d'instruments avait prévenu que la lave
à les déborder des bouches de voile
corps s'en est suivi un effondrement de
toute une partie de la montagne qui lui
même a provoqué un tsunami
une vague géante de 11 mètres qui a
balayé le pied de la ville
en cette période de l'année lille était
presque déserte et le raz-de-marée n'a
fait aucune victime
aujourd'hui une équipe de volcanologues
franco italienne menée par anthony fini
zola s'est lancé dans une étude sur le
terrain qui devrait leur permettre de
disséquer l'intérieur du volcan et de
mieux comprendre ces éruptions
paroxysmale
[Musique]
alors trois bobines vont là-bas à
l'entrée de la ligne directe une va vers
les premiers abri et de descendre sur la
ligne directe
leur but est de mettre en place un
dispositif géo électrique constitué
d'une toile de six câbles déroulée sur
le volcan cette technique d'imagerie
doit permettre de reconstruire les trois
dimensions de la montagne grâce à sa
conductivité général l'objectif faire
étudier la structure d'un volcan par
l'intermédiaire de ces mesures
électriques c'est à dire qu'on essaye de
voir où circulent ce que nous on observe
en tant que conducteur sol ça va nous
permettre d'une part la structuration le
passé homogène bien évidemment d
hétérogénéité et sérénité sont
fondamentales à comprendre pour
connaître les zones de faiblesse et la
présence d'eau dans le volcan est
particulièrement importante parce que
c'est elle qui peut occasionner des
éruptions paroxysmale si on a
interactions entre le magma et l'eau
il
donc au final c'est arrivé à mieux
comprendre ces gros événement qui se
passe sur l'île il ya des blocs qui
retombe un petit peu partout jusque sur
les maisons et donc pouvoir mieux
comprendre le fonctionnement du volcan
et mieux prévenir aussi les dangers avec
ce nouveau matériel de surveillance
le conduit volcaniques
se situe à une distance qui est très
proche de profondeur mais très proche de
l'endroit qu'on va investiguer donc
tenter de mieux comprendre ces
interactions entre l'eau de pluie qui
s'infiltre et qui est susceptible de
créer des éruptions relativement forte
dans le cas d'interaction au magma
c'est vraiment un avantage de pouvoir
s'approcher aussi près de cratère actif
ça on peut pas se permettre sur
développement plus explosif non mais
quand même à des distances qui sont
ridicules de cheminée l'hôtel
c'est la très grosse logistique donc on
sait pas ce que ça va donner
il y à il ya quelques jours quand même
d'installation pour installer ces 2 km 5
le cadre d'un côté à l'autre du volcan
première fois qu'on teste ce dispositif
à l'échelle mondiale il n'y a pas
d'autre équipe au monde qui ont un câble
au silo pour faire de l'investigation
profondeur va descendre quand même à 500
mètres de profondeur donc de la haute
résolution c'est-à-dire qu'on va pouvoir
faire la géologie réellement comprendre
la structure du volcan jusqu'à 500
mètres de profondeur
voilà c'est la dernière dernière manif
donc on connecte tous les 40 mètres les
électrodes donc soixante quatre
électrodes depuis le sommet jusqu'à la
mer
et puis ensuite il n'y a plus qu'à
qu'injecter du courant alors stromboli
est un bon point de départ parce que en
fait on sait qu'il ya des interactions
on à demain au niveau de ce volcan on
sait qu'il ya des zones de faiblesse
aussi et des risques de déstabilisation
c'est ce qui s'est passé en fin 2002 en
décembre 2002 donc c'est un bon point de
départ c'est à dire quand on sait que a
priori on devrait trouver quelque chose
d'intéressant et bien évidemment à
partir du moment que le dispositif
marche on peut imaginer son application
sur d'autres volcans c'est l'objectif
malgré la volonté humaine de comprendre
et de protéger malgré les instruments
toujours plus performantes et adaptées
aujourd'hui encore les volcans provoque
des éruptions imprévisible et inattendu
au pied de la cordillère des andes
le chaiten dormait depuis près de 9000
ans sous une épaisse forêt primaire tout
le monde avait oublié qu'il s'agissait
d'un volcan actif et personne ne l'avait
placé sous surveillance
le 2 mai 2008 son éruption a surpris
toute la communauté scientifique et
aurait pu créer une véritable tragédie
sous les tonnes de cendres de cette
irruption soudaine 7000 chiliens ont été
évacués en urgence et dispersés dans
tout le pays
forcés d'abandonner leur ville du jour
au lendemain
[Musique]
le connaissant vient de l'identité du
volcan la ville est fermée interdite à
toute présence humaine jusqu'à nouvel
ordre
[Musique]
un an plus tard les réfugiés ne sont
toujours pas autorisés à revenir chez
eux mais un équipement de surveillance a
été mise en place pour aider à décider
du sort de la ville et de ses habitants
le sismologue français denis legrand
suit l'évolution du volcan chaiten
depuis le début de l'éruption
[Musique]
à travers le regard des caméras les
volcanologues découvre d'un volcan
toujours actif et une ville qui semble
se faire engloutir irrémédiablement sous
les cendres
la rivière qui mène directement du
volcan à la ville a remporté avec elle
le ventre de la terre
les avalanches de cendres et de boue ont
détourné le lit du rio et ont traversé
en plein coeur la ville déserte
progressivement la terre gagne sur la
mer de la même façon que s'est construit
toute une partie du chili la cordillère
des andes bâtisse et terrasse au bord du
pacifique plus dramatique encore pour la
destinée de la ville de ses anciens
habitants
c'est cette menace faite de pierres qui
ne cesse de croître au sommet du volcan
en mesurant le champ magnétique autour
du chat n les volcanologues peuvent
évaluer les mouvements de magma à
l'intérieur de l'édifice jusqu'au bout
du monde les techniques de télémétrie
leur permettent d'étudier à moindre
risque l'immense variété de ses
montagnes vivantes ici un dôme de 600 m
est apparu au centre du cratère c'est
une nouvelle montagne qui est en train
de naître ce qu'on ait fait d'un magma
trop vis que pour s'écouler à
l'extérieur mais à l'intérieur c'est une
bombe à retardement qui en 6e dôme
chauffé à blanc s'effondre sur lui même
ou s'il éclate dans une nouvelle
explosion
il pourrait brûler la ville à son pied
sous un nuage pyroclastique exactement
comme à pompéi lire deux mille ans
lors des premières explosions il y a un
an les nuages de cendres avait soufflé
quelques milliers d'hectares de forêts
primaires sans parvenir jusqu'à la ville
hé hé oui
même pas
je
malgré les menaces bien identifiés
certains habitants ont décidé de revenir
vivre chez son ils sont une soixantaine
de chiliens qui veulent tout y est le
volcan qui ont décidé de ne pas croire
aux dangers il est parfois trop
douloureux de se résoudre à abandonner
ce fonds a construit pendant toute une
vie
[Musique]
mais le danger après une éruption n'est
pas uniquement pour ceux qui restent au
sol
il plane également dans les ailes
les poussières volcaniques ont certaines
caractéristiques qui en font de
véritables pièges aérien ces fines
particules de roche sont comme des
éclats de verre durée tranchant qui ont
un grand pouvoir abrasif
elles sont capables de dépôt lire
n'importe quelle surface de métal de
plastique ou de verre et d'endommager
ainsi sérieusement les avions de grandes
lignes qui traverse les panaches la
taille minuscule des particules leur
permet de s'infiltrer partout notamment
dans les ventilateurs des moteurs
d'avion leur fort pouvoir corrosif oxyde
et ronge le métal rapidement un des
incidents qui a marqué l'histoire de
l'aviation et celle du capitaine éric
maudit à bord de son boeing 747 nous
allions de kuala lumpur à perth à
l'ouest de l'australie
il s'agissait d'un vol en soirée très
sain mais l'ingénieur et à sion et deux
pilotes a dit le moteur numéro 4 s'est
éteint donc j'ai regardé c'était le cas
il était en train de s'éteindre prénom
numéro deux et un numéro trois et nous
les avons tous peur
l'avion entame alors une interminable
descente jusqu'à ce qu'il sorte du nuage
de cendres et que les moteurs ne
redémarrent l'un après l'autre
ce qui est effrayant c'est que plus on
approchait de la ville plus il y avait
de brume à travers le pare brise qui est
ensuite devenu un épais brouillard
quand nous avons demandé quelle était la
visibilité au sol
ils ont répondu qu'elle était un film ce
n'était pas le cas pour nous alors
quelque chose m'a fait regarder sur le
bord de mon pare-brise et je voyais
parfaitement à travers
visiblement il était arrivé quelque
chose au parc le pare brise du 747 avait
été entièrement démolie par les cendres
abrasives du volcan galunggung dans les
années 80 les dégâts causés par les
cendres aux avions de grandes lignes ont
coûté plusieurs centaines de millions de
dollars aux compagnies aériennes pour
surveiller ces nuages toxiques un réseau
mondial d'observation satellite a alors
été mise en place une veille volcanique
des routes aériennes
toute la difficulté est de savoir faire
la différence entre un nuage de cendres
est un nuage de vapeur d'eau de
connaître son évolution dans l'espace et
dans le temps
les ingénieurs et les météorologues
développe pour cela des capteurs
capables de mesurer la température des
nuages depuis l'espace d'autres outils
mesure la longueur d'onde émises par les
nuages de façon à déterminer les
contenus gazeux de chacun neuf centres
d'observation et de conseils sont
répartis dans le monde pour fournir leur
expertise à l'aviation civile en cas
d'éruption volcanique les modèles de
prévision tourner pour anticiper
l'évolution d'un nuage dans les
différentes couches de l'atmosphère
vingt ans après la création de ces
centres de surveillante un volcan qui
dormait depuis presque deux siècles va
mettre à l'épreuve les analystes et les
prévisionnistes
en islande le volcan eyjafjallajokull
est entré dans une éruption
spectaculaire le 20 mars 2010
le monde entier regarde fasciné cette
terre vivante qui joue avec l'eau et le
feu
[Musique]
les spécialistes savent que les cendres
du volcan islandais peuvent rapidement
toucher l'espace aérien européen
mais les nuages qui s'échappe pour
l'instant ne sont que de la vapeur d'eau
et reste inoffensif pour l'aviation
civile
trois semaines après l'ouverture de la
fissure une seconde éruption va devenir
beaucoup plus problématique
il s'agit cette fois d'une éruption sous
glaciaire qui expulse un nuage dense
chargé de cendres à plus de 10 km de
hauteur dans l'atmosphère
les modélisations de l'évolution du
nuage aux différentes altitudes ont
toutes confirmé que l'europe allait être
touchés cette nouvelle va créer un chaos
sans précédent
l'ensemble des aéroports européens ferme
ses portes pendant cinq jours entiers
chaque jour les compagnies aériennes
perdent plusieurs dizaines de millions
de dollars
le monde occidental se retrouve soudain
paralysé
[Musique]
au sixième jour le nuage se dissipe et
les avions peuvent reprendre leurs vols
mais le volcan toujours en éruption
continue de faire peur
les volcanologues savent tous que sous
les glacier d'islande sommeil des
volcans bien plus explosif ils savent
que les panaches de certaines éruptions
historiques ont plongé dans la nuit des
continents entiers pendant plusieurs
mois ils savent qu'il faut s'attendre un
jour à faire face à un scénario beaucoup
plus dramatique encore les forces
telluriques peuvent rapidement entraîner
une véritable catastrophe économique
dans le monde et les scientifiques ne
pourront jamais l'empêcher
[Musique]